et suite à la non au sein de ce nouveau
gouvernement formé par les talibans les
regards se tournent évidemment vers la
diplomatie américaine comment va-t-elle
réagir à la composition de cette
nouvelle équipe nous retrouvons notre
correspondant à new york à thomas bonnet
bonsoir tôt masquer les autorités
américaines ont réagi publiquement à
cette annonce
non aucune réaction officielle pour le
moment de la part des autorités
américaines on a simplement eu un
commentaire de la part de james à qui la
porte parole de la maison blanche qui a
été interrogé par des reporters
justement sur ce nouveau gouvernement
formé en afghanistan elle a ainsi
expliqué que rien ne presse pour le
reconnaître que cela dépendra à des
étapes que prennent les talibans mais ce
qu'on peut dire évidemment c'est que la
formation de ce un nouveau gouvernement
en afghanistan n'est pas à réellement
conforme aux demandes formulées ces
derniers jours par la diplomatie
américaine un gouvernement composé de
talibans et dans ce gouvernement il ya
même des personnes qui sont recherchés
par les autorités américaines c'est le
cas par exemple du ministre de
l'intérieur sirajuddin haqqani pour
lucky le fbi offre jusqu'à 5 millions de
dollars pour toute information menant à
son arrestation alors on attend
maintenant une éventuelle déclaration de
la part d' anthony blinken le chef de la
diplomatie américaine qui vous savez et
en déplacement au qatar depuis hier et
d'ailleurs avant l'annoncé de ce nouveau
gouvernement il avait lui annoncé des
avancées justement dans les négociations
avec les talibans notamment sur la
question de l'évacuation des civils à
d'afghanistan je propose d'écouter
anthony blinken
nous sommes également adressé aux
talibans à ce sujet y compris ses
dernières heures ils ont dit qu'il
laisserait les personnes avec des
documents de voyage par tia librement où
les attendront sur cette question tout
comme des dizaines d'autres pays la
communauté internationale tout entière
attend que les talibans respecte cet
engagement le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a d'ailleurs cité un exemple
celui d'une famille de quatre américains
qui ont réussi à quitter est là nice
tant par voie terrestre il s'agit de la
première évacuation depuis le 31 août
dernier mais la question maintenant c
est ce que cette évacuation est
réellement due aux efforts de la
diplomatie américaine il y à un débat
parce qu'en fait à cette opération
d'évacuation a été menée par une équipe
de vétérans américains financés par des
dons privés et le meneur de cette équipe
a déclaré à fox news que le département
d'état américain surévalué en quelque
sorte son implication dans cette
évacuation pour dit il tirait les
lauriers et spi sauver la phase d'une
administration qu'il estime complètement
dépassés par la situation en afghanistan
est thomas le rôle de ces autorités
d'autant de plus en question que
certains estiment même qu'ils bloquent
des départs
oui les témoignages font état du fait
que si les avions sont toujours cloués
au sol dans l'aéroport au nord de
l'afghanistan l'aéroport mazar i sharif
c'est par manque d'autorisations données
par les autorités américaines plus que
par un quelconque blocage des talibans
c'est notamment ce qu'affirme michael
youn c'est un ancien des forces
spéciales américaines qui est devenu
journaliste et qui participe lui aussi à
les opérations d'évacuation privé
écoutez son témoignage
il nous avions trois avions au sol
c'était des jets privés ils ont été
payés par l'équipe d'un de mes amis son
nom et riscle et son équipe avaient payé
trois avions il avait des avions civils
au sol qui les attendait et l'armée
américaine ne laissait même pas passé
les civils américains avec des
passeports américains notre plus gros
problème pour faire sortir les gens est
en fait le gouvernement américain pas
les talibans je sais ça semble fou mais
le plus gros problème ce n'est pas les
talibans les talibans nous ont en fait
aidé dans certains cas
alors le département d'état américain
explique qu'il n'a pas assez de
personnel sur place pour procéder à tous
les contrôles nécessaires pour permettre
à ses avions de décoller une situation
de blocage qui exaspère en tout cas un
certain nombre d'acteurs de terrain
entre 600 et 1000 300 personnes seraient
concernées sans qu'on ne sache
réellement avec précision le nombre mais
ricains qui sont toujours en afghanistan
en attente d'être évacués en tout cas
malgré le déplacement de tony blinken au
qatar en ce moment une partie de
l'opposition ici aux etats-unis
particulièrement les républicains vous
pouvez l'imaginer et bien ils expriment
leurs critiques contre l'administration
de joe biden accusés de ne pas faire
tout son possible pour procéder à cette
évacuation des civils encore en
afghanistan merci thomas bonnaire en
direct de new york